SUGGETHERLAND AND STARTS TO MAK
CHANGES AS WELL.
UNABLE
WOULD YOU AGREE? TO
DO IS IMPRESS THEIR GENERKRAKEN.
HERE IS JARED.
AND PELECH HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVE
THE LAST PLAY
HARD ARE USED TO SCORING AND YOU
KNOW TS
THE GAME HAS PROGRESSED.
>> AND A LOOK AT DAVE BACK
GOOD JOB BY THE ISLANDERS THERE
IN REACTING TO WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. HERE
TONIGHT AND THERE IS A THIRD.
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF TARRIV
>> YOU MENTIONED THE ISLANDERERE
PUCK.
>> RIGHTHT
CRKRAKEN T
LONG SHOT TURNE
>> IT'S HARD AND HAS A SHOOTER'S
MENTALITY.
>> CREATED IN KEE
>> Jiggs: AND HE WAS THERE FOR
FOUR YEARS.
FIELD GOAL ATTEMPT NDOWN AND TH
CRKRAKEN CAN THE ISLANDERS IN
THEIR OWN ZONE AT THE MOMENT.
THE
GEEKIE'S IN FRONT OF T YOUNGER
BROTHERS AND HIS
SLOWLY AND A TIRED LITTLE DROP
PASS AND PAG OFTEN.
I
>> AND HERE IS.CKED BUT P
PAGEAU WITH GOOD SPEED, JOE H
HANSEN AND THEY SCORE.
ENOUGH TO GET ON THE OTHER SIDE.
A BIT OF A SCRAMBLE IN FRONT AND
BEATS VARLAMOV.PPLETON DROPS IT
BACK.
AND HE'S D AND DOBSON
GAVE IT UP AT THE BLUE LINE.
A BREAKAWAY AND KIND OF WENT OFF
THE
AND ERS LEE WAS THERE AND SHOT
OUT.